hello everyone and welcome to a really
really awesome game from 1879 uh it's a
game between william robert ballard and
the joseph george uh
fagin and i haven't been able to find uh
well not any information regarding this
gentleman
but i did find one sentence about
william robert ballard and i will read
it to you because it's very interesting
uh it says dr william robert ballard jr
was born in naples italy in 1848
he was a strong london chess player in
the late 19th
and early 20th century and his father
was a native of new york and for some
years the leading american dentist in
london
so i guess there was a thing and also uh
robert william robert here is the
brother of uh luisa mathilda fagan
now either his sister and the hoodie guy
here have the same last name
uh or these two gentlemen are brothers
in law
uh so this could be the first ever game
we're showing
where the hoodie guy is someone's
brother-in-law could be just a
coincidence maybe they
just have a last name but you know it's
hard for me to say
now there aren't a lot of games played
by uh either of them
but uh william robert ballard has some
very very
nice games played against some very very
strong players of that age like joseph
henry blackburn like henry bird
uh and such and he even has a a
brilliant victory against henry bird
and uh we are going to show uh during
the morphe saga we will show
uh a morphe's match against uh a bird
that's
where we're going next but this game why
i'm showing you this game
is because it is the immortal uh eight
pawns game
uh or maybe no pawns game uh since you
guys enjoyed those so much and as you
can see white is missing the knight here
there is no knight on b1 which is often
uh the case when a very strong player
would face an inferior opponent he would
often uh give them you know odds of
overnight or maybe even a rook or
or sometimes in rare cases even a queen
uh but that being said uh let's check
out the game and then you guys uh
can can tell me if this is truly the the
immortal no pawns game so white here
opens with
e4 now we're not gonna do well on the
opening too much as the white is already
missing a night from the start so
it would be silly to kind of uh name the
openings uh
you know their usual names but uh sorry
about that
but since a lot of the things will be
similar uh
we might talk about it a little bit so
here e5 and f4 if the knight was on b1
we would have the
the king's gambit on the board black
would accept the gambit and white would
play knight to f3 so this is basically
standard theory
uh without uh the sorry about that
without the white knight being on v1
uh we have bishop to e7 and now as black
is uh preparing to play bishop to
h4 check to mess up black's uh
black spawn structure and also you will
have to play g3 could be could be a
problem so here bishop to c4 making room
for the king on f1
and the black goes for it with bishop to
h for check and here
if this was a modern game and the white
was not missing the knight on b1 we
would see a move like king to f1
however we we have g3 here because white
is uh
already down material and he wants to
open up the f-file castle and use this
uh
f file uh you know for attacking
purposes
uh we have f captures in g3 and now of
course uh
weak castle here and now you can see
that black could have some issues here
if he allows this sacrifice for example
bishop captures then the knight comes
into the game
game opens up a double check could be
could be very strong for white and i
forgot to mention about something i
often mention
uh the reason i'm wearing a hoodie in
this video is because we are honoring
the hoodie guy we don't know who he is
and don't have any additional
information on him
so uh that's why whenever we we have a
hoodie guy in the game
i will also be wearing a hoodie and you
know it's it's only a plus if you guys
are wearing a hoodie as well
so here knight to h6 black waits with
any capturing here
he wants to develop and hopefully castle
with his king so here we have d4 by
white
and now we have castles uh if this was a
regular game i repeat and if the knight
was on b1
here it would be that in this position
on move seven we have a completely new
game or rather game that
has never been repeated again uh but uh
you know
without the knight on b1 uh it happened
much sooner
so here black now feels comfortable to
grab the pawn h captures
uh on g sorry a white captures on g3 we
have bishop captures and now king to g2
putting pressure on the bishop here
so bishop back to d6 here you could
start
with the d5 then of course if captures
you just capture the bishop and if not
you make way for your pieces to be
developed because uh
even though you're already up material
from the beginning of the game
you have to start developing your pieces
here so far you're not doing a very good
job at it
so bishop back to d6 not an optimal
placement for the bishop
and now rook to h1 white has a semi-open
h file and he
of course hopes to use it for attacking
purposes uh one might even consider
capturing the knight on the next move so
here
queen to f6 uh and now uh while you
could capture and
open up a black's uh black's king white
continues with
e5 and it seems like black is losing a
piece but not really because queen to g6
check and now the king has to react to
this we have king to f1
and now knights to f5 offering the
bishop here because
knight to g3 check is coming and then uh
you're gonna lose the rook
so here rook the g1 first attacking the
queen
and now we have knight the g3 with check
now here uh white could consider giving
up uh
giving up the rook for for two pieces
but it's not going to be
it's not going to be all that much for
example you could play captures captures
in the
pawn captures here but uh you were
already down material you're not
you're not really gaining anything b5 is
coming then the bishop comes into the
game and it's going to be
it's going to be very tough for for
white to play this so instead we have
king to f2 now with a double attack
on the knight and still keeping the
threat of uh just e captures on d6
now comes knight to e4 with check king
moves once again
we have king to e1 and now bishop to be
for wit
check you could go back with bishop to
e7 but
this is this is much stronger because
now we have c3 blocking this
and then now comes just knight captures
and c3
and black is just saying uh you know my
position is much better i was already up
material when
we started this game why not to give up
a knight here to pick up the rook on a1
so white without much options here we
have captures captures with
check a nice fork here the king and the
rooker under attack king f2
and now the the black king is still
under attack so you have to
move the queen before capturing the rook
so queen to c6 now
with an attack on the bishop and also on
the rook and here
you don't really have all that much for
example if you if you try and save the
rook with rook to be one queen captures
on c4
and the black is simply simply up too
much material and you don't have to
worry like
you could go bishop h6 you just play g6
you you give up the rook here
uh but there's still not much for for
white to go on
as soon as you can you're going to play
b5 develop the bishop bring the knight
into the game
and you're just up too much material so
here instead we have bishop back to d3
uh white decides to give up the rook
instead
and the bishop captures on a1 now here
we have d5 a very sneaky move by white
uh of course now if the if the pawn is
captured you just pick up the pawn on h7
with check and after black reacts to
this you're just gonna pick up the black
queen on d5
so instead after this d5 move we have
queen to b6 with
check bishop to e3 and now queen to b2
with
check king to f1 uh white now hopes
black will do something silly uh and in
fact black does like here
you should you should either capture the
pawn you should maybe play d6 try and
bring the
the bishop into the game somehow however
black decides to go for f5 and it does
make sense if white captures on f6 alpha
song
black will capture and you're going to
have a nice open file ready to attack
the white king
and if you don't then black just has a
very nice
pawn here for example the the white
bishop no longer attacks the h7 pawn you
can push
to f4 when you're ready and so on so
here uh
white goes bishop to d4 attacks the
queen and the bishop here
uh black says okay i'm just going to
capture here
on a2 get the queen out of the way but
even capturing with the queen
would be sufficient here for black
because black is just up so much
material for
for example captures captures uh your
rook is under attack once you move the
rook captures on e5
and once you play d6 and develop at
least two pieces
there's just nothing for white to do
here this pawn is
very solid here you're not going to be
able to open up the position and
you're just down too much material so
here instead after bishop d4
uh black could have gone for this but if
black was a you know
a player of a certain string that you
know can spot such a move
uh he probably wouldn't be getting uh
uh getting any any uh odds uh in the
beginning of the game so rook captures
an a2
that's a queen and now bishop captures
sun a1 so grabbing the rook as well
and now queen captures on d5 getting rid
of
one of the pawns and here here we have a
very interesting move
e6 and e6 now opens up the attack
towards the black king the rook and
bishop are attacking the
the g7 pawn and here black defends with
the g6 and you can see that
although uh black seems to be doing very
well he's he's up
material he's you know has a very solid
defensive structure here
uh his pieces are very much undeveloped
so you uh
it doesn't matter if you start to being
up if you start up a piece
if you if you don't develop then it
simply doesn't matter
and here black is uh in fact completely
lost uh so
feel free to pause the video and try to
find this move uh that wins the game for
white
while i give you a couple of seconds you
know try try and take down the the
hoodie guy
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
move with the knight in the center of
the board and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it's
knight to e5 and here uh
it it's just completely winning because
you're threatening to pick up the g6
pawn but not only that
the knight from e5 covers the c4 square
and bishop the c4
could become very very dangerous in some
lines so here we're just going to show
uh what can happen for example if black
makes any move
some silly move let's say knight to c6
seems like a nice developing move
uh you're just going to go knight
captures on g6 this is what we mentioned
that this is very dangerous
and now you can see how the position
nicely opened up the pawn covers the f7
square
and there just isn't much you can do
here for example if you capture the
knight it's just very simple uh rook
captures on g6 with
check king h7 and queen to h5 is check
so that's not possible on the other hand
if you tried the absolute best defense
uh
for you to free the f8 square for the
for the black king
then he captures on d7 with a double
attack here threatening to to bring the
queen into the game let's say knight
captures here now the problem is just
bishop to c4 and uh black loses the
queen
so there's also that and even if you try
there's not much you can try because you
cannot capture with the rook just spawn
captures here with
check brings the queen into the game so
nothing you can do works here
so here after g6 knight to e5 wins the
game however
uh if this move was played we would
probably never show this game because we
need
all eight pawns to be sacrificed and
this is what white wanted to do here
most likely and he played e7 it seems
like a very strong move
and uh you are giving up your last pawn
so here
rook to e8 defending uh and uh this rook
38 was
actually not the the most precise way to
go because you are still
up so much material so keeping on to
that rook
uh that doesn't really make much of a
much of a
point you you should be probably doing
something else
uh but you know it's it's very hard to
decide what that is
maybe develop you know but you know
it's it's incredibly incredibly
difficult to find the move here
so rook the e8 was played but now comes
queen to e2 defending the pawn but also
preparing the main threat which is just
shifting the queen to b2 as the bishop
is here
and then you want to deliver checkmate
or if not possible then maybe go
king to king queen to h8 and so on
uh so here we have queen to c5 black
says
uh all right at least we're gonna pick
up pick up d7 pawn but now comes
white's main idea queen to b2 and now
there is nothing
uh more to be done queen to g7 is the
threat of checkmate
so to defend this uh black eliminates
the e7 pawn and
guards the g7 square but it doesn't help
by capturing an e7 black eliminated
white's last pawn so there are no more
white pawns on the board
but now it's checkmating two i'm sure
you you can all see it the queen to h8
with check king to f7 and now comes
knight the g5 checkmate
all of the squares are covered
discovered by the bishop discovered by
the knight and discovered by
the queen so the black king has nowhere
to go
and uh yeah we could we could actually
use this for for a thumbnail maybe
uh we'll see how it goes uh so yeah uh
this is uh
i just stumbled upon this game so i
thought it was a nice one a nice one to
show
it's a it's a it's an older game but you
know
i know how much you guys enjoy older
games and this especially one that
where the hoodie guy is featured and i'm
pretty sure this game could have
gone the same way even if white had that
uh
knight on b1 that probably would have
sacrificed everything
and uh but but it wouldn't be the same
here is just beautiful because
white uh gave the odds of a knight and
then he sacrificed all of his spawns
even though he had that win
it'd be very interesting to actually
know
uh if white founded the 95 move or he
just wanted to sacrifice all of his
pawns
uh maybe he's just you know for the
beauty of it maybe let's just
try and get rid of all of them so it's
hard to say
but yeah that's uh the game between
william robert ballard and joseph george
fagan also the hoodie guy i do hope you
guys enjoyed it
i would like to thank david turnbull uh
me harisman henry spragens uh andres
mikhail nielsen
and uh grabagenta for your contribution
to my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
uh continue of course the coverage of
the morphe saga checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world
so thank y'all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day